we
might not be alone in the universe
scientists from all over the world have
their eyes and ears wide open trying to
detect signals of life beyond our planet
but
we're a bit tired of just sitting and
waiting
so hop on our spacecraft because today
you have a very important mission
to search for alien life
how would we prepare for this journey
what kind of life would we be looking
for
and
what would happen if we found it
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we went on a search for alien
life
so far we've detected over 4 000
exoplanets in our galaxy
and there may be as many as trillions
to make your expedition easier you'd
need to consult with nasa first
nasa has developed the confidence of
life detection scale
or cold to measure progress in life
detection research
the scale has seven levels ranging from
signal detection to follow-up studies
once life beyond earth is confirmed
first you'd need to look for
biosignatures
this is physical evidence of past or
present life on another planet
such as chemical compounds or molecules
that indicate biological processes
if an alien astronomer was taking
measurements of earth they'd look for
oxygen and methane those are
biosignatures that indicate life on our
planet
if you're a celestial technology geek
you might scan for techno signatures
these are signs showing the negative
uses of technology that cause artificial
air pollution
this means aliens could figure out we
exist because of all that smog we send
into the atmosphere
embarrassing right
now that you know what to look for
where would you look for it
sometimes the quest for knowledge can be
just as hard as looking for alien life
but thanks to skillshare i can be part
of an online learning community and
expand my skills and explore my personal
growth all from the comfort of my own
home
you know whether you want to learn more
about astronomy photography or improve
your painting skills skillshare has the
courses you need to invest in yourself
every course is ad free and more are
added every week you'll never run out of
things to discover here
look running a team and creating content
takes up a lot of my time but with the
course how to organize your workflow to
maximize productivity by ali abdol i've
learned balance in my work life and how
to juggle multiple projects at once
personal growth is an endless journey
and with abdel's course i know i can
take my team and myself to the next
level and right now the first 1 000
people to use the link in the
description below we'll get a one month
free trial of skillshare you know with
so many courses to explore on skillshare
maybe these aliens will contact us
instead
you could start this search in our own
cosmic backyard
alien life could be hiding on the
subsurface oceans of europa
one of jupiter's moons
or deep beneath the surface of mars
ground telescopes have already detected
methane on mars
sending probes to measure surface levels
that already puts you on the second
level of the cold scale
or you could go further and look for
alien life on rocky planets outside our
solar system
you'd need to locate planets orbiting a
star in its habitable zone
that's the area where a planet is not
too close to the star and not too far
allowing for temperatures to be just
right for liquid water to form
scientists have already done the hard
work for you here
using the kepler object of interest
exoplanet archive researchers identified
systems that might have rocky planets
that meet the criteria they found 24
super habitable planets
and one of them is very promising
koi 5715.01
is roughly 1 billion years older than
earth
which means it's had enough time for
life to develop
scientists estimate that the best chance
of discovering life is on planets
between 5 and 8 billion years old
that makes koi 5715.01
a perfect candidate
now while it's a bit cooler than our
planet it could support life if it
contained enough greenhouse gases
so let's say you detected bio signatures
on koi 571 5.01
now you've got yourself a potentially
habitable exoplanet
nasa would then have to confirm that
there were no measurement errors and
that the planet really has the potential
to host life
the next step would be to predict what
type of source could generate such a
signal
scientists would need to confirm this
signature couldn't have come from a
non-biological source
once that was done you'd be on level
four of the cold scale
at this level scientists would test the
signal with other advanced measurement
methods
nasa's powerful james webb space
telescope would confirm the exoplanet
contains a strong signature for life
and you would be able to proudly say you
found alien life
and then scientists would be able to
kick-start follow-up studies at level
seven
that means you'd now be ready to fasten
your seat belt and see these aliens for
yourself
but
how would you get
there yeah that's when things get tricky
koi
5715.01 is located almost three light
years away from us
that's 700 times further away than
proxima centauri
the closest star to our solar system
if we used developing ionic propulsion
engines it would take over 55 million
years to get there
you'd have to make use of some
futuristic solutions like a laser sail
this technology uses ultra thin mirrors
to capture the momentum of light from
stars
and then uses this momentum to push a
spacecraft to high speeds
if you managed to build laser sails with
diameters of 320 kilometers you might be
able to reach koi 571 5.01
in about 8 500 years
setting aside the fact that you wouldn't
live that long
what would you find once you got there
alien life could be extremely complex or
very basic and the alien's appearance
would depend on the world they evolved
on
things like gravity density and the
amount of energy given off by its star
they would probably have something that
resembles fingers or tentacles to build
tools
and since two legs and two arms are more
efficient than four legs the aliens
might have evolved to walk upright
you want to invite them for a stroll
well
first you'd need to figure out their
form of communication
and it might be a little more advanced
than speech or writing
they might just exchange pheromones or
even use telepathy
and finally you'd want to know how they
reproduce
we can't be sure if alien reproduction
happens by seeding fission or egg laying
so maybe it's best to leave the romantic
stuff here on earth
while your journey to find alien life
might be successful in our hypothetical
story
in reality it's still very far-fetched
with technology evolving to detect
signals from outer space we might be
able to identify them at some point but
there would still be the issue of
getting to them
what good does it do knowing something
is out there if we can never see it up
close
i mean unless aliens were already living
inside earth
but that sounds like a story
for another
what if
[Music]